uh the elk boys used martial law did is
that what kind of help popped that
record crazy yeah like steve will do it
really love that record yeah it was like
a lot of things you know the pandemics
social media the protest video was dope
it was just that moment
we couldn't have planned it you know it
just happened you you got jessie uh this
is the second video he's been in but
this video he's like she killed it he's
like in the video i've had this idea for
like a minute you know you've seen it
with like the pop star yeah
i thought that was so funny i've been
wanting to do that for a grip and jesse
and i were tossing the idea he was down
like was it pretty good
killed it i sent him the lyrics he's
like i got this i'm about to [ __ ]
hold him he loves it he want to be a
rapper or something bro he was in dude
he recorded here bro i
remember
no
no but he was like yo we should do a
comedy
skit how about the skit when yeah when
he's got homies in the booth and he's
like
yeah i'm just thinking like more
tropical vibes like oh yeah
he's awesome that [ __ ] was hilarious i
like the knuckles jesse good dude
jesse's a good dude man yeah so yeah
because like i feel like did you barely
just meet him during the pandemic yeah
like i had a i met steve will do it
because he's from oviedo which like my
high school
winter springs in oviedo are like rival
schools so like we had some mutual
friends and [ __ ] i knew he was he
brought me out to the no spot and then i
met them and jesse just he's on my way
blank good dude shout out to florida man
producing steve will do it and caskey
and caskey